hey youtubers is charlie this is gonna
be my comic con preview for Wonder Woman
they're bringing it to comic-con is
going to be big presentation gal Godot
is gonna be wonderful so naturally they
started to drop some teasers just to
hype things up they released a couple
images that give you a better look at
her costume now if you look at early in
the film you can kind of see the
transition as she meets Steve Trevor she
learns about World War one and she's
inspired to help humanity out I'll talk
about in a second because there is some
setup that we learned about for justice
league into how the Amazons figure in
two world history as it applies to New
Gods more galactic things but that's
kind of like a Justice Society story so
it's kind of like the thousands of years
of history leading up to what's going on
in the DC Universe right now the story
of how the Amazons basically bailed on
humanity when it used to be their task
to protect it so you probably read some
version of the Wonder Woman origin story
if you're brand new to the character I
would say the one in rebirth right now
is probably the best version to go with
just because that's going to be like the
new Canon going forward so she's the
daughter of ippoliti in Zeus Hippolytus
the queen of the Amazons really all the
Amazons are badass but look at robin
wright penn here she plays her aunt so
robin wright penn is going to be a
badass sword-wielding amazon in this
movie I'm so excited she's kind of an
Amazon on house of cards but she wears a
very different suit of armor speaking of
which there been a lot of jokes about
Wonder Woman's you know red look it's
kind of like a captain america thing
whereby you can see how she chooses
those colors that you know they evoke a
very particular theme so the MacGuffin
of the film is World War one so as the
world starts to rip itself apart she
tries to make peace that's kind of what
brings her into man's world like okay
I'm inspired to help these people out
typically in most Wonder Woman's stories
when you look at the other Amazon's
though they don't look so favorably on
humanity like her mother Hippolyta it
just completely checked out she's just
like screw him let him all tear
themselves apart but just like all
children born of gods you know rebelling
against their parents she decides to
help out so part of the fun of the film
is going to be seeing her get that
classic armor going from the traditional
Amazon armor to donning her you know
classic Justice League armor and they
haven't really confirmed it but I'm
expecting some sort of minor Justice
League nod you know what i was talking
about New Gods grand history of the
world
when all those news reporters got to
visit the set of Justice League we
learned that the three mother boxes that
you see in this you know this Lex Luthor
seen here were left on earth one of them
is held by the Amazons so we might
actually see the mother box when we go
to Themis Kira because the way they
explained it happened like 30,000 years
ago in human history now that might have
just been a typo you know maybe it was
3,000 years ago but it's at some point
in the ancient history of the world
Darkseid came the Amazons Atlantis in an
ancient one just someone that are
referring to as the ancient one fought
him off the mother boxes were left
behind so because the Amazons are so
ancient we might see reference to that
and drawings are like background scenes
so just keep your eyes peeled for
justice league Easter eggs for Darkseid
war I like the idea that Geoff Johns
just did a run on Justice League called
dark side war and there was a dark side
war in the DC movie universe they also
cool thing about geoff johns they just
revealed that he co-wrote the Wonder
Woman script which i think is totally
appropriate we knew he was doing that
for Ben Affleck's Batman script but i'm
not sure why they waited to announce
this till previously because you know I
mean Geoff Johns is just doing so much
awesome stuff from the DC Universe right
now I'm guessing they were just waiting
and so they were gonna start promoting
the film a little bit more but you have
to remember i know there's comic-con is
coming next week they'll probably drop
some more footage i'm expecting like a
new Wonder Woman trailer but the film
isn't out till june of next year so i'm
not really expecting them to do crazy
marketing till next year that's actually
gonna be fun like right around that June
time is when spider-man homecomings
coming out so spider-man and Wonder
Woman are going to rule in the spring
guardians of the galaxy two is coming
out a little bit earlier that's going to
be like the tip of the spear in 2017 but
in a couple weeks in about two weeks
Suicide Squad is coming out there's
going to be a whole bunch of Suicide
Squad stuff at comic-con too so i'll be
doing videos for all that stuff so be
sure to subscribe to get that and that
actually reminds me congratulations to
this week's giveaway winner Alex
Gonzalez you want a twenty-dollar amazon
gift card be sure to private message me
on the back end of my channel so and get
your contact details so I'm doing a DC
giveaway there's going to be comic-con
giveaways next week too for pretty much
everything i'm doing like Marvel DC Game
of Thrones so there'll be a new round of
the giveaway the next time I post a DC
video if you guys have any requests just
feel free to make them in the comments
but they'll be all kinds of comic-con
stuff
week I will be doing a couple videos
that will explain exactly what kind of
videos I'm going to do when they're
gonna post when everything's happening
it is gonna be really awesome for the
next two weeks like we have all this new
Star Wars stuff this weekend then next
week is Comic Con I would totally like
to meet the masochist that schedule
these giant two events back-to-back but
the times so next I would be some game
of thrones there'll be some comic book
stuff on Sunday why you guys wait for my
next video to post you can click here to
learn more about what happened during
that Justice League set visit the new
information we learned about the movie
and you can click here for my breakdown
of the guardians of the galaxy 2 teaser
that James Gunn just dropped thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
Oh